so we have to talk once again about
Republican Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell Mitch McConnell has really
emerged as one of the most insidious and
pernicious forces in American politics
during the Trump administration and he's
doing really great things for
Republicans I mean if you are a
Republican and you are paying attention
to what Mitch McConnell is doing and has
been doing for the last three or so
years you probably think that the guy is
absolutely brilliant and one of the best
political operators in the game right
now and that's true I mean from the
Republican point of view Mitch McConnell
successfully orchestrated the blocking
of Merrick Garland's confirmation to the
Supreme Court under Barack Obama in 2016
he got Donald Trump an additional
Supreme Court pick who will be on the
court presumably for decades and
influence American culture and society
and and justice for a very very long
time in significant ways Mitch McConnell
participated hugely in the obstruction
and disinformation around the release of
the Moller report and blocking various
versions of it and killing bills meant
to release the report it's a very long
list of Mitch McConnell's successes and
now he is blocking bills that are meant
to fight election interference there's a
bill HR 1 that the Senate could take up
which would do a lot to protect
elections and to fight interference and
Mitch McConnell is not even giving it a
shot he says it's completely dead on
arrival and the argument that McConnell
and some other Republicans are making is
that the bill was a poisoned bill that
it goes too far that it contains the
wrong stuff and does the wrong things
but what you have to understand is that
this is once again Mitch McConnell's
well enough calculated for the
Republican base opposition because
they've opposed dealing with foreign
election interference at every
opportunity it's not actually about this
particular bill it's a much bigger issue
they claim to believe the Moller report
right even though they miss state what
the molar report says when they say the
molar report says no obstruction no
collusion they appear to believe into
trust
in the moola report well the molar
report also says there was significant
foreign interference Russia was involved
WikiLeaks was involved with Russia this
is a huge deal Russians access voting
systems and I think it was like two
dozen states 20 states or something like
that and Mitch McConnell has stood in
the way of actually dealing with that
interference in our elections at every
single step
you've got robert muller and the
intelligence community and everybody who
has any connection to reality warning US
foreign interference is already
happening for the 2020 election it
happened in 2016 and mitch mcconnell is
making it so that absolutely nothing is
done about it and of course i mean if
you want to follow the money
mitch mcconnell is tied to russian oil
money Mitch McConnell has voted to drop
sanctions on Putin connected Russian
oligarchs Mitch McConnell received more
than three million dollars in campaign
donations from a Russian oligarch linked
company all alt-tab holdings it's all a
swamp Mitch McConnell is right in there
with it and it would be great if
Kentucky got its act together and remove
the sky because I have to admit he's an
extremely effective Republican operative
arguably one of the most effective in
recent history his involvement over the
last I don't know more than a decade
specifically with the courts and helping
Republicans influence and control not
just the Supreme Court but federal
judges and the courts and justice system
at a bunch of different levels this is
one of the most successful and mostly
out of the public eye political
operations in modern times and part of
why it's been so effective I mean listen
controlling the courts helps Republicans
win controlling the whole of the courts
helps Republicans get their way when it
comes to social issues when it comes to
corporate power and the the sort of
deference to corporations over the
individual but part of why it's
effective is not only because of what it
does but because it's under the radar it
gets way less media attention to over a
10-year period slowly chip away and take
control of the courts in many different
ways
that it also doesn't generate as much
loud and public activism against it
because a lot of people don't know that
it's happening and even if Donald Trump
leaves in 2020 is voted out in 2020
Mitch McConnell and others I mean I
don't want to give McConnell more credit
than he deserves but he deserves some
pretty significant amount of credit here
they will have succeeded in this
rightward swing of the American justice
system in a way that is totally separate
and distinct from Donald Trump
beyond Donald Trump just getting that
extra Supreme Court pick thanks to Mitch
McConnell obstructing Merrick garland
back in 2016 so it's pernicious it's
dangerous but you've got to hand it to
Republicans they have been doing great
things for themselves terrible things
for the country terrible things for the
world
terrible things for just the average
person in the United States middle-class
person lower middle class poor people
but for their agenda this has been
extremely successful I think this is one
of the biggest areas where Democrats
have just totally dropped the ball we
talked about local organizing is a place
where the left I don't want to say we're
not good at it but we've not been good
at it we've not done it well when it
comes to influencing the justice system
it's an other area where the left has to
get it together and you know what I know
I've said this a couple of times this
week when we even had people on the left
in 2016 maybe not a lot but some of them
were loud saying Hillary Trump these are
both centrist clowns I don't like either
of them and if it's not going to be
whoever right Bernie Jill Stein whoever
it was if it's not going to be that
person I'm indifferent between Hillary
and Trump this is why the right
continues to get favorable decisions on
corporate power and abortion now and so
much else because they understand
getting your person in there to pick
Supreme Court justices and to appoint
federal nominate
federal judges it has a massive impact
they are beating us on this I don't want
to keep losing on this so let's actually
understand it for what it is extremely
important and a very well-crafted
strategy that Mitch
coño has been a big part of let me know
what you think I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show today's program is sponsored
in part by our friends over at Loch Ness
crypto dot-com the team is based in
Boise Idaho and they've made it their
mission to help just everyday people
navigate the world of cryptocurrency and
they've been doing it since 2012 they've
actually been teaching a course about
cryptocurrency at the Boise State
computer science department for years
and they've taken that curriculum and
sort of packed it into an easy to digest
course that's now available to anybody
who wants it called the cryptocurrency
starter kit and this is the type of
thing that crypto has really been
lacking and it's one of the reasons we
we maybe haven't seen adoption of
currencies like Bitcoin and others on a
larger scale normal people who are not
tech experts need a step-by-step guide
that's easy to understand about how they
can get involved with cryptocurrency in
a way that is sort of safe and
manageable and that's what the
cryptocurrency starter kit provides it's
a five part video series which includes
how to safely obtain Kryptos where to
set up your accounts how to protect
those accounts from hackers importantly
how to move crypto into physical
hardware wallets and also how to just
prepare for the future of the space you
also get a free physical hardware wallet
it's sort of like a flash drive where
you can safely store your Bitcoin or
other Kryptos offline and you also get
one hour of one on one phone or Skype
mentoring with one of lochness cryptos
experts they're the only company in the
crypto space that offers a service like
this and it all comes with the
cryptocurrency starter kit they have a
special offer specifically for the David
Pakman show audience if you click the
link under this video you'll get $200
off the cryptocurrency starter kit check
it out using the link down below